we have spoken to this man many times
on this program and frequently
after a super bowl um he's been calling
nfl games for westwood 1 radio and you
know i'm a monday night football host
for that
so
we've had conversations after super bowl
weekend in which he's been sorely
disappointed not hearing his name called
for the hall that changed this time
around
he got a door knock
and he is in the pro football hall of
fame 2022 class thrilled to have here on
the rich eisen show tony beselli on the
mercedes-benz vans phone line how are
you tony
well rich i'm doing good i'd like to
thank you that's a good intro it sounds
much better than usually after the super
bowl when we talk
right so okay uh tell me about the door
knock from anthony munoz of all people
fellow trojan and fellow now hall of
famer that ought to be pretty cool for
you
yeah well if you notice like everyone
else had someone from their franchise
with hall of famer so obviously
jacksonville i'm the first so there's
there was no one to knock at my door
and if you could have listed rich all
the people
in the world
that
i would have wanted to open up the door
and see
welcome me to the hall of fame
there's there's not a better person than
anthony munoz you mentioned he went to
fc
he set the standard he's the best ever
in my opinion the position i played
he's a guy that i wanted to be like it's
like that's who you would model your
game after uh over the years we've
become friends
um and he's always been super supportive
and so like that moment it was going to
be awesome regardless if you knocked on
the door to be clear because i mean
you're going to the hall of fame which
is the highest individual honor you can
get in the game of football
but when it was anthony munoz and i open
that door and he's in his gold jacket he
gives me that big hug and my family's
behind it
it's a moment i'll never forget it's
like one of the you know we all have
highlights in life like these big
moments you know getting married
having kids
um
whatever they are and this is going to
be one of those for me
and what was that moment like with your
wife tony because i know with my wife um
she um one of the many things i love
about her is whenever
i i i'm slighted or she feels i've been
slighted she's not only there to you
know pick me up or give me the you know
kind of you know screw them sort of uh
conversation
um
so what was it like to actually
celebrate this moment with somebody's
been by your side for all those times
where the door didn't get knocked
yeah it's awesome we've been married
it'll be 27 years this year i mean we
dated in college
um she was there when i got drafted
uh she was there for the big moments as
a as a player as a jaguar you know
hawaii all-pro
you know alignment here all the big
stuff
she was there when i got hurt too and i
was found out my career was over and she
dealt with you know
me being down and depressed and
i mean she is
she's my best friend and and
to be able to and she's always she's
like you just said it rich i mean she's
the one who's in my corner like shoot
like you can like my wife is the nicest
person in the world literally the nicest
i've ever met outside of two things if
you talk bad about her husband or kid
she will come kill you
and
i mean just like watch out like i'd be
careful angie miseli's coming after you
if you talk about her husband or her kid
right and for her to be a part of that
moment for me i mean
it's obviously i'm going into the hall
of fame but i like she's coming with me
and my kids and my teammates and like my
close friends and and the best part
about it is you know they voted on the
18th of january i the knock happens on
the 27th so that's what nine days in
between right
she got a phone call from the hall of
fame on the 19th the day after letting
her know that i made the whole thing
because they have to schedule the knock
and i travel a lot like where am i going
to be
and she kept it a secret for me for nine
days and she played it up perfectly she
acted like she was worried that i hadn't
heard anything
you know i'm getting anxious and and
when it all happened i looked at her i
said i'm going to kill you
what else have you been lying to me
because you're really good at it you're
really good at this
wow it was awesome it was awesome yeah
so because they have to let somebody in
your family know because they can't yeah
bring anthony munoz and you know you're
out get you know doing a a grocery run
right i mean like you gotta and and i'm
sure you you know uh you have to make
sure that everyone's around that you
wanted to be around
and she had to arrange but that had to
kill her right for eight oh yeah i don't
know how she did it rich i mean she had
so she had to get my my mom was there
she had my stepmom because my dad passed
away in uh last year so he
which was one of the probably the only
disappointing thing because he couldn't
be right you know i was really close
with my dad but you'd be my stepmom my
kids
some live in south florida some live in
gainesville university of florida she
had to get all them there
and she orchestrated this entire thing
and
and i had no idea i i opened that door
and i'm like you've got to be kidding me
it's anthony munoz
and his jacket right extending his hand
and um just gives you that big hug and i
was just like this is all and then we
got to sit down and talk and auntie and
i are friends so
it just made it that much special we had
got some bubbly out little champagne
toast and uh
and it was awesome it was just
like it says like it's what life's all
about because to me making the hall of
fame is amazing it's like huge but to be
able to experience that with the people
you love
and who've been there and have been
cheering you on
and
you know to just it was it was glorious
it was awesome because the five years
before that we'd be in a hotel room or
whatever we'd find out i didn't make it
and they'd all be crying i'd be sitting
there the only one not i mean i was
upset but like my wife's crying my kids
are crying
and so just to take that and remember
those disappointments where everyone
experienced that together which is part
of life too and that's why you love
family
um but to see them as excited and
and go to the super bowl and experience
all the big moments it was it's just
been a great ride
it's been awesome tony becelli here on
the rich eyes and showing again to go to
the super bowl in southern california
right where you played your college ball
and
you know and who the hell knew there
would ever be
you know a super bowl back in los
angeles and let alone
you know um a moment for you uh where
you could see maybe some of your old
college mates or
hit campus that's pretty cool too right
we had a party we had a party thursday
night after the honors jags helped post
on campus at usc at heritage hall and
rich you mentioned about people being
back in l.a for the first time
the last time i played in 1994
at usc was the last year the rams and
the raiders were in la and so like the
full circle and come back
and
to be inducted the hall of fame
in la
the whole thing it was amazing it might
you know we had this big party and
probably i mean there's so many great
moments but
i'm just gonna brag my wife some more
because she you know my as i mentioned
my dad died on uh memorial day last year
which anyone who's lost a parent you
know i mean that's just devastating and
i knew um the year
you know earlier that year when i found
out i wasn't going to make the hall of
fame again that he probably wasn't going
to make it because he had cancer
and uh
and so you go through it you go through
all the emotions and it was emotional
when i found out i knew my dad you know
he wasn't here with me
and so i what i didn't know and we so we
had this party thursday night at the
after the honors at usc and and at the
end of it or near the end they run this
video it's all my friends and family
like congratulating me and just really
cool little moments making fun of me
which i love i love when people take
shots because it's just it's good stuff
and at the end of it
all of a sudden my dad pops up on the
screen
and
my wife and one of my best friends a guy
named eric murphy 12 days
before my dad died convinced him
to do a video congratulating me on
making hall of fame
just it's like and
rich
i'm getting emotional just thinking
about here i couldn't even watch it
i'd put my head i put my head in my
hands
and i i still haven't got up like the
strength to go back and watch the whole
thing because
he lost me
when he said his opening words he says
i'm so proud of you son and i was like
i'm done
and but it was such i mean i just
i mean the fact that my wife and my
friends thought about doing that and uh
making that a reality so just like so
many cool moments wow
i'm a fortunate i'm a fortunate man rich
i i lost my dad in 2019 i'm getting
choked up hearing it you know because
i'm part of that um unfortunate
fraternity of of of having lost my
father and you gave me goosebumps that
had
that had to be incred my gosh
that that actually happened and now you
can actually see the video and you are
that hall of famer man and you're the
first
as a jaguar i mean it's incredible it
really is um yeah it doesn't replace it
not being there of course but you know
what it doesn't i mean
it's his best i mean it was awesome wow
tony
yeah awesome tony becelle here on on the
rich eisen show
so um
you know i i just mentioned you you were
the first jaguar to go in the hall right
uh you were the first jaguar ever
so
one day
now you will get to knock on the door of
another jaguar
right like if this is the way that this
is gonna be done from now on you're that
guy whose door do you think you should
be knocking on tony
give me some names no i'm a you know i i
mean i i'm gonna bring up a guy who's a
semifinalist this year he had to be a
finalist and fred taylor
and i you know i think fred taylor was
probably one of the most
underappreciated running backs
um in his area he has over 12 000 yards
he averaged 4.6 yards a carry
um you know he gets knocked because he
you know didn't make all pro and you
know not a lot a big number of pro bowls
but if you go ask anyone who played with
them or anyone who played against them
there was not a more dangerous back and
his stats back it up
and i'm hoping you know sometimes in
smaller markets you don't get recognized
i mean a guy like that would have played
in dallas or new york in a big market
with the numbers he put up and the way
he played
um he was a superstar and i thought
firsthand i got a block for him
and he's a guy that i think needs to get
recognized and it would be what it would
be pretty cool if one day i get to do
that he's been a semifinalist hopefully
gets in the room where they can debate
them and we'll see what happens tony
burcelli here on the rich eisen show uh
before i let you go i want you to put
your uh your paparazzi hat on um and
tell me what you think won
what was the thing that won super bowl
56 for the rams i can guess a number of
the guy
but there
you know uh he wasn't the mvp either so
um what do you make of that rams win and
why it happened
tony so it was the least amount of
football i've watched in the super bowl
because i was too uh busy enjoying
myself
i understood what i watched and going
back and looking at the game overall
um
it goes back to the fact that the basics
of the game of football if you can't if
you can't control the line of scrimmage
you can't block people up front it's
really hard to win now the bengals had
overcome it and they've done it so many
times at nine saxons and titans they
overcame it their defense had played so
well in the playoffs
but at some point in big moments it's
going to come back to haunt you and it
did and i don't know how aaron donald
and that's taking nothing away from
cooper cup what an amazing year he had
and he's an amazing player
but aaron donald in that defensive front
dominated
joe burrow and if they didn't
the bengals win that game uh because joe
burrow was going to tear him apart and
but he never had time and aaron donald
who is just a man among
you know he's a man he's he's uh
dominates games he takes over and he did
and at the biggest moment he made the
biggest play so that's you know that's
where it comes down to so
who does aaron donald compared to a guy
that you were trying to block
back in your day yeah i think you know
he reminds me a lot of john randall
you know similar size explosive really
powerful you know
uh
i think maybe i think aaron's probably
maybe a little quicker
but i think the mo i think john randall
probably his motor goes a little
stronger
a little harder you know john randall
was a guy who's like every snap backside
front side was just going to come after
you and try to take your head off and
i'm not saying aaron donald lopes or
anything aaron donald's you know so
quick at the point of attack
um
but that's probably you know body type
and how he played
uh you know you look at people talk
about is aaron donald the greatest
defensive player ever i don't know and i
don't really don't care i think it's a
dumb argument because i would say what
about bruce smith what about lawrence
taylor what about deacon jones
i mean like you have to i mean what
about ronnie lott what he did at safety
um and so i think it's just dangerous we
live in a culture where it's recently
biased
and what we see the latest is the
greatest and that's you know aaron
dahl's in the conversation and that's
all that should matter because all the
guys when you get to that level it's
like i was joking with bruce smith when
he came up on stage after he introduced
me at honors gave me a big hug and
congratulated me and he had he had his
red jacket on yes 100 year team and i
said i said bruce thanks
i'm so excited the hall of famer but
that jacket means you're in the hall of
fame of hall of famers
and ultimately that's what aaron's the
type of uh player aaron donald is well
you know that's why bruce smith was
wearing it right that's you know he
that's a flex that's a flex but here's
here's here's what really matters when
it all comes down to it tony is every
single person you name with the
exception of deacon jones is going to be
there to shake your hand
for years to come
in canton ohio and that crazy ass
randall with his war paint and
everything that trying to get in your
head
all those days and years
you're his peer and the greatest club
period for football in canton ohio and
that's it and you will be the one
shaking aaron donald's hand when you
welcome him in
it's so cool and i can't wait to be
there and watch this all wash over you
man like i've seen it so many times that
right now your first blush in it and
you've got all these preparations and
you're going to feel like you're getting
married again right because if you have
invitations and and all of that you know
and and you're going to it's going to
feel like your second wedding right but
then when it comes time to get the
jacket slipped on you and to reveal your
bust and walk into that nichey luncheon
and see all of those gold jackets around
you and you're one of them now
it is so amazing i can't wait to watch
that for you tony can't wait it's gonna
be great rich i appreciate it and as
someone who has loved the game of
football since i can remember it's all i
ever wanted to do and the fact that what
you just described i wouldn't be a part
of
is you talk about
getting emotional and just like having
to pinch yourself um making sure it's
not a dream because it's better than any
dream i've ever had
congratulations high five your wife for
me seems like she pulled off quite the
caper it seems like she pulled off quite
the caper so
i appreciate rich thanks for having me i
this is i i
i appreciate you having me on always
when i did make it and now that i made
it so thanks
we have to we have to keep it fair and
balanced thank you tony you'll be well i
love it take care man you got it tony
beselli right here in the rich eisen
show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here